we're here at CES 2016 I'm Justin hey
well joined by Peter Brown and the
biggest talk of the show has been
virtual reality and I don't think
there's any argument that the two
biggest names in that or oculus VR and
the HTC vive now we finally got a chance
to try these back-to-back for me for the
first time and I think for you as well
Peter and trying them back-to-back being
able to really compare them it has kind
of opened my eyes to some things I
didn't notice about them before yeah I
mean oculus is getting a lot of the
press right now because look you can
pre-order one and there's a price you
haven't rough idea when it's going to
come out HTC is sort of catching
people's interest because they have a
partnership with valve but beyond that
the hardware to me was actually more
impressive in the grand scheme of things
for one any oculus demo I'm doing where
I can move it's like a three by three
foot square for the vibe demos where I
can move because they have these two
emitters that you place up in these
different corners of your room you have
a much larger space to work with and the
thing that they've added now is a camera
on the front of the headset and what
that lets you do and what it lets the
headset do is give you an idea of when
you're getting close to something in the
real world so you're looking at you know
the in-game graphics but we get close to
something it actually reveals this
translucent image to let you know hey
stop but almost immediately what that
means is that the vibe is a much more
exciting product because you aren't
limited as much and limitations in VR
are going to be the biggest killer so
that front-facing camera I think solves
one of the biggest problems one of the
biggest criticisms that I have with me
are is that it cut you off from the rest
of the world being able to double tap a
button and see things around you it is
something that's so important for this
kind of experience but I tried the
oculus first and then I went over to HTC
vive so there was something I didn't
notice that you stood out a little bit
more for you going the opposite
direction and that's the field of view
is a little bit limited the field of
view is it limited on the oculus rift
compared to the current model of the HTC
vive that said the vibe does have more
of a screen door effect when you notice
individual pixels on the displays and
that is one thing that takes you out of
immersion in quote-unquote as much as we
can really say that now as does the
field of view with the oculus so both of
them have their shortcomings at the
moment I will say each device is way
more comfortable than they have been in
the past showings the vibe in particular
it's lighter in general but it also has
sort of a dual strap thing going on and
back your head feels really light I
didn't actually notice that I was
wearing anything bulky having a light
headset something that's comfortable is
gonna be really really important one
thing that's a problem for both of them
though is this cave
that's sticking out no matter what
they're gonna have to have something
that tethers it to the PC in one of our
demos we had a person who was just
walking around behind us and making sure
we didn't trip over it but that's what
are you gonna do and that's in your home
that's something you really have to
solve for that is another problem they
have to solve and there are a lot of
problems and then again one of them
being software which we talked about you
know recently as well and while it's
fair to say that any of the demos on
these these platforms could have been
used in either headset these companies
are showing specific demos and so we can
really only say what they have based on
what they've shown us and the stuff I've
seen on vibe is much more consistent and
impressive at this point eval Curie has
always been the standout demo on oculus
but when I was doing things today in the
vibe such as working in a it's like fake
a job in an office manipulating all
these objects and other demos that
required a lot of dexterity and movement
it was consistent and it's in it and it
works the whole time a few the demos
we've done oculus such as bullet train I
was picking up a gun and trying to fire
it and I'm like reversed it was firing
at me I mean I actually had a lot of
calibration issues that may have been
due to the format of the demo in the
room the people who set it up but that's
the reality of this these are people who
do this for a living when an amateur
gets it at home and they need to set it
up how many problems are they going to
encounter and so that's indicative you
know from a professional standard that
the oculus is falling behind that might
actually be the case of the real world
graphically to me oculus just looks
better but the experience of being able
to walk around and be in this world and
the vibe it's it's so important and they
do it so well
they really do yeah I mean there was a
point where a guy put a chair in front
of me he told me to sit down in it and
it was like okay oh okay like I could do
that
so controllers are also very important
because each of these devices you have
to interact with the game somehow
controllers are the way to do it very
different controllers from both
companies HTC is doing sort of a a
wiimote like approach and it feels you
know like a comfortable controller it's
easy to use or aren't that many buttons
could stay the same for the oculus it's
a little bit more cumbersome because you
have to slip your hands into these rings
but more importantly it's the feel of
what you're holding
so for oculus for example it feels a lot
like a gun yeah and that's something
that works well for the things that we
do which are shooters which are things
that are asking you to pull a trigger in
these games when you pick something up
it it feels very natural I the HTC vive
s don't feel bad and they what they do
feels right but it seems I'm being able
to have the extra buttons being able to
have an actual
thumbstick on there I feel like that
absolute that that helps me relate to it
as it gave yeah I mean it's okay let's
say we're six months away from you know
at least seeing one in the headset on
the market if you had the money to
afford both maybe even oculus was out
first would you jump and pay for oculus
or would you wait for the HTC vive being
able to walk around in the in the HTC
vive like that's still such a great
experience like that's something
incomparable and I think that's
something that's so important for what
virtual reality is going to offer in the
future it's not a seeded experience it's
not something that you only get in your
living room on your couch it's something
that's gonna be a part of your entire
life and HTC is kind of that promise I
know it's not there yet but being able
to walk around a room being able to
switch between what I'm seeing the real
world and what I'm seeing in virtual
reality like the the proposition of what
that could offer is so exciting yeah I
mean oculus is definitely laid the
groundwork for the new VR movement
they're certainly trying to target a
price point that sort of meets consumer
demand in a way with the advances in
technology for VR but I have to applaud
HTC for what they're doing and I think
that is the one that I am most excited
about if they put both in front of me
today you know I mean I'm plus look at
valve is partnered with HTC as well like
Steam VR will be the HTC vive I'm sure
will also integrate with oculus and
other headsets as well
the HTC is the official partner they
have better tech already maybe it'll be
more expensive I don't care that's the
one I want to use
you